hallo mein name ist luca meine damen und
herren wir haben so unfassbar viele
leute in den letzten wochen in die
kommentare geschrieben luca du musst du
unbedingt mal auf michael smolik
reagieren also das ist jetzt gerade
nicht michaels sondern dass hier michael
smolik ist polizist und spielt bei der
serie ruhrpott wache mit es allerdings
ein sehr lustiger polizist der oft mal
zu komischen mitteln greift das video
das wir uns heute von der report wache
mit michael smolik anschauen reißt alles
oder nichts michael smolik in action
das kann nun eis werden wo welche kurz
ein wenig kontext zu geben was ihr schon
passiert ist die beiden polizisten
michaels musik und seine kollegen haben
einen anruf bekommen dass in dem park
ein drogendealer mit drogen dealt ja mit
was auch sonst michael frolik ist nun
mit seiner kollegin in den park gefahren
und sie sehen diese beiden personen
alles weitere schauen wir uns jetzt
zusammen an allerdings nicht mit
normaler geschwindigkeit sondern mit der
holden geschwindigkeit
schwester alter sie blutet sogar die
schwester was machen sie mit dem stopp
in ghana war ich hier ist ein halber
geschwindigkeit ein gruppe sonst auf der
welt hier wohnt ruft einen rettungswagen
für die bern hat nun priorität sich um
die überfallene frau zu kümmern was
passiert sein könnte oder haben sie
überhaupt was sie sehen
ich liebe an als wäre die drunken
überhaupt was gesehen hatte noch
durchaus gute chancen hin zu stellen
traurig nur durch ist zu alleine und wir
hatten noch ein verstärktes team das am
anderen ende des parks war ja sie da
wenn er da so sitzt und er ist mollig
steht da und schaut dahin jetzt oder was
erst mal in deckung gehen
die streifen kollegen
wie kommt die ganze zeit so vor als
schaue ich mir irgendwelche leute als
polizist verkleidet besorgt man kann
dass molly geht in deckung was steckt
sich glaube ich hinten findet geraten
drogendeal stadt beziehungsweise findet
nicht statt und erstmalig geht jetzt
nach vorne ich weiß nicht ob er ihn
jetzt auch schon fest nimmt oder ob er
sich von ihm
der läuft ja echt langsam beginnt wird
aber noch ein halber geschwindigkeit
dieser in graz überall irgendwie lustig
also den drogendealer bitte mit ab auf
ihn zu und ich versuche abzufangen also
die polizisten von der einen seite
fahren jetzt auf den drogendealer zu und
er michaels molly quartier und versucht
den drogendealer dann abzufangen
tatsächlich geht der plan von
polizeikommissar michael smolik
das sieht schon dass eine methode und
die kerne er schon neuerdings sich mal
drogen ihr song auf raubüberfälle
begehen und andere verrät andere
verletzten eine junge dame ich hier
niedergeschlagen sagte sie nicht ich
besseres gibt das geld aber auto war
alles klar
frage da der drogendealer nun allerdings
gefasst wurde habe ich uns noch eine
zweite folge rausgesucht mit michaels
mutig und zwar diese hier hochzeit auf
umwegen michael smolle geregelt kurze
vorgeschichte auch hierzu eben noch mal
um euch ein bisschen kontext zu liefern
es findet gerade eine hochzeit statt und
die braut wurde von zwei leuten entführt
unter ist gerade schlägerei und jetzt
kommt der michaels modick mit seinem
kollegen
august
ich lege ich dir alles aufgeboten was
die titel der gott der sich die haut
ging ja völlig auf dem boden war sehr
schwer sich in dieser situation
überblick verschaffen wir sind darauf
gezählt dass wir einfach im bruchteil
von millisekunden einfach sehen wer böse
wäre es gut dann haben mir jetzt noch
mal die richtigen leicht festgestellt
die wada als wert selbst oder gott auf
erden was hier passiert ja du bist ja
gerade rein gegangen oder sie alle um
geboxt
[Musik]
die haben aber alle schon ordentlich
blut in einer presse ort
es gibt eine art smolik komplett um
was geht denn da wieder abbaut die wir
haben halt in dieser situation sehr
emotional reagiert ich war seine braut
eben verschwunden erklärt es nicht muss
man versuchen sich wieder zu fangen
stehen sind das ist mollig alter aber
was ist denn mit der ehefrau wo ist denn
die plötzlich hören die beamten auf dem
motor gerollt
jetzt gehts hier ab freunde jetzt mal
endlos
online ich hoffe da kommen ja okay ihr
kollege kommt von der seite oder kommt
smolik
was nach berlin
was geht da jetzt plötzlich ab als von
aus dem gebäude raus sind haben wir
gesehen wie ein fahrzeug wegfahren
wollte die braut saß hinten verletzt auf
der rückbank das habe ich natürlich
blitzschnell reagieren hören und
kombinieren können unbekannter täter
wollte flüchten muss über der tür
springt ihn festnehmen kann ich glaube
weil diese eine stelle gerade sehen sind
schnell reagieren können und kombinieren
können leute die eh schon 70 reden dann
noch in slow motion reden dass seine
lachmuskeln
allem anschein nach wollte der
verdächtigen die braut gewaltsam
verschleppten kosmologie zu frau es ist
[Musik]
da stellt wieder die wichtigen fragen
was mir eins übergebraten mit dem
tablett der rdb es auch kommt gleich mit
seiner hand gebarens ideen
ich glaube es ich hoffe dass es einige
gibt die sowas auch so lustig bin wie
ich oder ich halte mein wort einfach nur
komplett hängen geblieben ist
wir sind jetzt hat man verstanden
versorgen
wenn du hier auch komplett zugerichtet
aus
30 40 hier steht auch alles schwarz auf
weiß dann nicht mehr nur die o2 hilf mir
madeo natürlich anstiften der
gefährlichen körperverletzung dann
eigenen begangene gefährliche
körperverletzung an der braut hh dieses
dorthin und bedrohung das mussten wir
noch alles nachher mit
aber das wird viele und große
konsequenzen mit sich ziehen
da können wir uns ja nur glücklich
schätzen dass der michael frolik holt
immer wieder alles geregelt hat an der
stelle durch das heutige video ist
allerdings auch beenden bei der liebe
freunde ich habe letztens mit juli im
bett lag haben wir uns ein video von der
rub und wache angesehen und haben uns
das in halber geschwindigkeit angeschaut
und das war ich ziemlich witzig deswegen
habe ich mir gedacht hey gucken wir uns
jetzt nur noch ein zwei weitere videos
von michael smolik an ich finde auf
jeden fall mega unterhaltsamen kann auch
sein dass sie es überhaupt kommt der
schweiz findet dann ist euer humor
wahrscheinlich einfach weiterentwickelt
als meiner wenns euch dennoch gefallen
hat er das gerne einen daumen hoch bei
diesem video da schreibt eure meinung
zum michael smolik und seinen manövern
gerne und in die kommentare und jetzt
kommt das auto
[Musik]